what is your opinion of samuel leeds
samuel leeds samuel leeds
samuel leeds i'm going to be responding
to a video
that was created about samuel leeds this
was
by a guy called mark parham and he's got
a picture of me looking like a devil
with devil devil horns but then an angel
halo
i guess that means like is he a devil or
is he an angel
or is he just a successful property
investor that does youtube videos
who knows let's find out i respect mark
as a business person i actually sold him
a house
like maybe four years ago i sold market
house um
i skim watch the video already but i'm
gonna watch it properly i'm gonna react
to it
the title is called samuel leaves truth
multi-millionaire's opinion of samuel
leet and his
property training business let's see
what the video says
[Music]
hello and welcome to my channel my
name's mark parham i'm an entrepreneur
and property investor and in this video
we're going to be discussing
one of the most commonly asked questions
to me what is your opinion of samuel
leads
now really that's the
most common question that anybody asks
you when you're talking with people and
doing your consultation calls
not how you doing no how can you help me
no no the most common question you can
ask
is what do you think about samuel leeds
really okay now the internet seems to be
obsessed so i'm going to give my two
pennies worth
in this video i'm going to do it
completely unedited
and you're going to know exactly my
thoughts on the whole business model
that samuel operates
is the internet really obsessed with me
i mean maybe maybe some people are but
yes come on mark add your two pennies
let's hear the world is waiting to know
what mark thinks of samuel leeds
so before we get into the video if you
give this a big thumbs up a big light
my marketing guy says that really helps
me out with the algorithm so have you
done that
so my name's mark parham i've got about
3 million pounds worth of uk rental
property
i've also got about a million pounds
worth of um projects
in development in terms of property i
run multiple
seven-figure businesses and i've been in
business about 15 years so i'm pretty
well versed with the world of business
and the world of investing hopefully
it's this experience it gives me a bit
of a balanced
view of the sensation that is samuel
leads
and all the controversy that sort of
surrounds his companies
and himself so let's have a look at what
it is that samuel leeds does
and why he's so controversial
so he seems like a pretty successful guy
and i always think it's important to try
and figure out people's agenda
you know like okay if he's successful
he's making good money
why would he do a youtube video giving
his opinion
on me i don't know what his agenda would
be but hey let's keep watching
so property investors with samuel leeds
is his training company this is really
where the controversy
is all around now what they do is they
sell training courses
on how to become financially free how to
invest in property with no money down
how to um become a deal source
lease option agreements all these sort
of strategies around the property
industry now initially samuel obviously
puts out lots and lots of free content
on his youtube channel
lots of which is absolutely fantastic
i've watched lots of it myself
i think it's really really good and then
there is a free crash course which again
i have attended
and i thought was a very good program
for anybody who wants to get a
basic knowledge of all the different
strategies and all the different things
that are available for you
in the property investing world i'm kind
of waiting for a butt here you know
he said like is youtube's great his
crash course is great i'm like
yeah yeah yeah i'm waiting for a butt
i'm waiting for a butt
the problem that this business model has
is that after you do the free crash
course
obviously there is advanced training
that's for sale now
any business that sells a product where
you can't guarantee
a positive outcome for your client is
always going to face scrutiny
and criticism from a select group of
clients that it's not successful for
he sells an intangible product a
training course something that you can't
really judge
on whether it's been delivered correctly
or not is it untangible
a training course i'm going to google
the definition of the word
intangible intangible is
not able to be touched not having a
physical presence so if you come along
to one of my training programs
it it is it has got a physical presence
it's a real thing
i don't know i guess it depends on
define intangible exactly i guess it's
no different from if you go to
um university is that a tangible
thing it's a service if you go on
holiday or if you have any kind of
consultation it's not physical like my
mobile phone is physical
but it's a service rather than a product
but now if samuel delivers his training
and for whatever reason that doesn't
work for the
individual and there can be many reasons
right entrepreneurship is not for
everybody
and trust me it's not for everybody
nine out of ten businesses fail within
the first three years and that's a true
statistic
that's not because nine out of ten
people couldn't be bothered it's because
starting and running a business
is very very difficult i would argue
that probably the reason
nine out of ten fail is because they
don't get
trained properly they don't get the
correct consultation that's why they
fail
if you look at my students my success
students or
all of my students i don't think you'll
find that nine out of ten of them
fail in fact it's probably more like a
flip opposite it's more like nine out of
10 of them
succeed why because they've received
training because they've received
a physical tangible service
so the controversy really is surrounding
the people who it doesn't work for
and that the training won't be
successful for so what can you do about
it
um i mean using my business mind there's
only really three or four options
number one you could give everybody a
full refund if they didn't feel that the
training was
was suitable and you could do that
within a a certain time frame
i know for example my taxi company if
we're late or if there's any big
problems we
give a free refund straight away given a
refund
because you as a taxi firm the taxi
demand doesn't
turn up that's fair enough that'll be
like me
giving training to somebody selling
training but then i don't turn up to
deliver the training and it doesn't
happen in which case
they should receive a refund the problem
is refunding somebody
because i turn up as a trainer and
deliver and help and support
and then they don't get results well
like you can't refund someone because
they don't get results because if you
did offer that
let's say i said if you come on my
training but if it doesn't work out and
you don't get results you'll get a full
refund guess what
no one would get results or hardly
anybody would because there's no
consequence there's no skin in the game
i think oh in that case i'll just turn
up and see what happens
whereas when people come and think this
needs to work this is on me
then they actually are more likely to
get results so i don't think the analogy
quite works
the second thing you could do is accept
training isn't going to work for
everybody you know
and you know ultimately some people
aren't going to be happy
and that is okay i don't know of any
business that hasn't
got negative reviews or that has managed
to make
every single potential customer happy um
so it's absolutely okay to have that as
an issue
i think option number two of saying some
people aren't gonna succeed and that is
okay
i mean i guess to a point you have to
just accept that
not you know we we had throughout the
whole of 2020
9.5 out of 10 that was our average score
of what our students rated us at the end
of training
i wish it was 10 i wish we had 100
so i guess to a point you do have to
accept that however
if you if you accept that apathetically
and just go not everyone's going to
succeed we'll just see what happens
my attitude is i'm going to act like
everyone can succeed
everyone will succeed everyone should
succeed and and that's how i'm gonna act
with expectations
and of course you know not everybody
will um but anyway what's point three
so the third thing that i could think
that you could do is you could have some
sort of entrance requirements to the
to the advanced training like if you
think about university
i couldn't just rock up to oxford
university right now
give them 20 grand and get in they would
say
mark you have not got a certifiable
level of intelligence high enough um but
that would be the answer right i
couldn't just enroll
at oxford university you are correct if
you want to go to certain universities
you have to have a certain intelligence
you have to have done certain things you
need to have a certain paycheck
right because you have to pay for your
name to be able to get into a uni
the problem is with that though is
they're they're coming to uni it's an
academic exercise
how is a trainer am i going to say to
someone you're too
done you haven't got what it takes i
started out
working class no money 17
i wouldn't have got into any
universities but thank god
there was mentors out there that took me
under their wing i paid for it
so i think who am i to judge
who's intelligent enough who's wealthy
enough i've had people say this to you
before they're like you should only
really work with people who have already
got money and already but then
what help the rich get richer or help
the
working class and middle class or poor
people
actually have a break and another thing
is this you know you're talking about
how you know maybe
i should make people get to a certain
point before they
do paid for training well i do how by
giving everybody free training first
the crash course youtube books cds they
do all the free stuff
and then for they qualify themself if
they like the free stuff
they do the crash course and it's free
and they're like you know what this is
really good
and then they qualify themselves and
they get a bit of an idea about how it
works they have their eyes open they
want to go a step further they want to
invest in themselves
then they they can only make that
decision i can't say you're too dumb
you're too stupid that's my opinion
what i would say is in terms of my
opinion of samuel leeds and his
companies
i have recently enrolled in the samuel
365 to get more broad knowledge
of his business um and also to get a
better understanding of himself as a
person
and the people that he surrounds himself
by and so far to date i've really
enjoyed those meetings
we've been doing a weekly webinar call
so i will come back and do a review of
samuel 365.
in the next couple of weeks so so far
mark has been happy
i'm glad to hear it and mark i welcome
you to
a review of samuel 365 and i'm sure
you have nothing other than good things
to say
i've got a little bit more information
for you he's got an issue
whereby the training will not work for
everybody
and that is just a fact and the thing is
you said i've got an issue
that not everyone's going to be
successful in that but i don't think
there's a property training company on
the planet
that has the success rate that we have i
don't think it exists
so i don't know why it's like i have a
problem i mean isn't that the case for
every single training company and
university on the planet
i hope this video has been useful for
you i've been mark parham please
subscribe
thank you so much i mean i think it's
healthy and
important to challenge people to test
to try and see how things could be done
better differently listen i'm growing
i'm learning my as a property investor
as a trainer
you know i'm open to critique so the
reason i responded to mark's video was
because he was genuinely just
challenging and asking questions he's
done the training
uh he wasn't saying lies he wasn't i
guess he was trying to clickbait me a
little bit but that's okay
so mark if you're watching this i wish
you all the very best in your property
business i wish you all the very best of
your youtube channel i'm glad you're a
customer
and i look forward to seeing your review
and guys let me know what you think
comment below do you think my response
was reasonable do you think mark's video
was reasonable let me know your thoughts
comment below and i look forward to
seeing you
next time